[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls we rapping now
we're rapping who you really are
notorious
p-i-g
[Music]
he don't want no trouble i was famous
before the internet
since 1935 i've been getting respect
this pig is lit
i'm super legit every time i'm out in
public people asking me for dicks
you nobody knows you when you walk the
street how your last name rhythm and
you're still off beat from beginning
to the end i'm here for all the smoke
you're squatting all star your squad is
all
jokes end up with one bar most famous of
all quotes this battle is now over the
bat that's all folks
space jam on new legacy with pg in
theaters and on hbo max july 16.
count to lady checker twitter abuela
let's do this what's happening bro
what did i miss hey granny speedy
hey aren't you lebron james it's an
honor for me to be a part of the space
jam
world hugs bunny knows who i am when i
was 12 years old watching space jam and
always having a love for bugs bunny
what's up doc
bring it here man are we ready
and now we need to reintroduce it to
kids today and show them how
unbelievable the looney tunes are and
how great our support of basketball is i
felt like it was a match made in heaven
i was excited from the very beginning
to play with you in a high-stakes
basketball game but yeah that actually
sums it up well
this is a fictional version of myself
but it's also kind of
who i am as well what works so well with
the character
is i was able to implement a lot of
things that i actually do
when the cameras are not on
family's everything you got that right
sometimes i'm just like how am i even
putting this position
to be a part of all of this it's so
challenging when you're
doing a scene and you gotta visualize
the tunes actually being there
just like i drew it up
for me being able to produce a movie
like this but also be able to star in a
movie like this it's very humbling for
me just knowing where i come from
[Music]
welcome king james
i'm a cartoon
[Music]
the computer dude kidnapped my son
what in the matrix hell
hey what'd you do to my son the only way
you're getting your son back is if you
and i play a little basketball
you want to play me in basketball
i need to assemble the lead team you
need a dream team
i'll take it from here sam shoot the
ball
let's try that again shall we we'll get
your son back
i promise what's happening
i look expensive introducing
the goon squad
well at least we're good oh and i almost
forgot
all of the tunes will be deleted so
come on guys the tune squad doesn't give
up if
i got
the machines producing multiple riley
coyotes
well that happened wow
[Music]
we need a boost a secret weapon come on
man granny's out here having a martini
at halftime
kate is gonna hate
[Music]
i think the effects that we have
throughout the film are gonna be the
greatest thing about the whole movie
space jam really takes advantage of all
the cutting-edge filmmaking technology
we've assembled such a tremendous team
because it's incredibly complex
we have all these textures and layers
and artistic complexities we really
wanted to make it film as handcrafted as
possible
while that process was to develop some
new tools to achieve that 2d aspect in
the 3d world we need a boost
a pick-me-up a secret weapon
we had to create every inch of this
insane eye-popping world
i look expensive it takes hundreds and
hundreds of artists to build these shots
let's get some birds in these seats how
big are these butts
a shot like that takes the better part
of a year you gotta be
kidding me oh you mad bro
we're gonna see the looney tunes up
we've never seen
there's gonna be so much going on in the
movie from one scene to the next
okay i got it new game plan
i've literally just been in awe of the
whole process
basketball camp is next weekend you got
amazing potential on the court
and i can help you get there that's not
what i want
dad you never let me do what i want to
do you never let me just
do me hold up wrong floor
that will smith i got to deal with this
what in the matrix hello
[Music]
welcome king james i am the king of this
domain
this is the server verse what you do to
my son where's dom
the only way you're getting your son
back is if you and i play a little
basketball
pete send this clown to the rejects
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this
i'm a cartoon what's up doc
i need to assemble an elite team to help
get my son back i know what you're
looking for
that dream team ma'am shoot the ball
let's try that again shall we
king james
welcome to the space jam
you gotta win this game
yikes
classic welcome to the space camp
i'm going old school on his butt
whoa welcome to the space jam
bye